laurent gerra la casse tête
si saisissant allemand à halle en mai
ces prix mais il ya toujours ce problème
vous le savez les imiter ne sont jamais
totalement convaincu des mutations mêmes
moyens que vous devez réaliser
non non je sais à paris mais nous mais
nous avions été voir l'or avec je me
souviens à charles aznavour vous en
souvenez certainement oui
1 dans la spectatrice de paris et nous
bavardions charles
s'il ya quelqu'un a des limites et c'est
bien lui devant et nous nous échangions
nos impressions limitée et c'est vrai
que ni l'un ni l'autre nous avions
l'impression réellement d'être bien
limitées quoi je peux vous dire est
d'accord il ya sauf le respect que je
vous dois chauffage vous entends parler
maintenant
oui vous voyez laurent gerra grèce est
terrible parce que maintenant
même pas grave le maire s'est croisé
dans une eau film sébastien ou dit
bonsoir thierry vous me parlez de placer
l'élève pour pas mal je suis désolé puis
je vous demanderai une chose simplement
chers amis c'est de ne pas me faire
aller aux [ __ ]
il m'a fait souffrir bonnes femmes
réclament ça ne fait pas marrer
obligatoire au nom l'horloge elle
oui totalement rodé très bien alors
maintenant ce que je vous demanderais
ces deux oui vendée nous votre livre
comme si vous étiez au téléachat voilà
tient ce livre extrêmement commode car
nous avons étudié le format pour que une
fois ouvert exactement la moitié il
recouvre parfaitement le visage les
jours d'ensoleillement un point et vous
permettre de rester sur la plage donc
tranquillement sans prendre de coups de
soleil
merci
alors bon solinhac assez étonnant quand
même au delà de la date où c'est à dire
que c'est des histoires d'animaux
absolument incroyable par exemple il ya
le les chevaux desberg l2 evian qui ont
fasciné le kaiser guillaume ii c'est des
chevaux qui savait trouver les racines
carrées oui alors évidemment c'est
miracle histoire extraordinaire c'est le
connaissant je suis un couple de chevaux
donc il avait un mec bien tresseur et
avec leurs jambes et leurs sabots il
tapait au sol et donner les réponses
donc on leur donnait un chiffre et il
donnait la résine carré voilà où là où
même la racine cubique
alors bien sûr ça paraissait totalement
éblouissant est époustouflant mais on a
fait des quantités de deux tests on a
essayé de 2,2 de piéger le dompteur et
régulièrement les chevaux répondez
correctement donc on n'a pas connu comme
pour me remmy roska qui était un numéro
13 de divination
on n'a pas connu le truc et comme pour m
y revenez me revient au score on
pourrait dire que c'est fantastique si
c'était vrai c'est encore plus
formidable si c'est faux voilà mais
voilà alors et sylvain mirouf que vous
connaissez et m'a dit l'autre jour qu'il
avait un document comme quoi le secret
avait été pénétrés et qu'il allait me la
porte et là j'attends paribas rien cette
histoire est que les histoires
absolument extraordinaire évidemment
avec vous et les six ans le crime qui
sont prêts à le chat qui décroche le
téléphone pour faire peur aux
cambrioleurs absolument c'est ça sur les
gens qui sont assiégés par des
cambrioleurs le chat s'est sauvé bien
entendu et abandonnant au monde elle est
forcément par hasard mais c'est hazard
qui veut bien les choses il décroche le
téléphone on est à l'époque où le
central est relié au téléphone
les vieux téléphones d'autrefois où on
passait par un central pour aller
communication l'opératrice qui repèrent
le numéro puisque c'est le numéro de
téléphone quand le téléphone se
décrochent dit mais qu'est ce qui se
passe est l'appel
elle n'entend rien et puis d'un seul
coup d'un seul elle entend le chat
miauler devant l'appareil et c'est
quelque chose qui ne va pas chez les
appels ailier envoie la police et on a
des griffes est donc c'est bien le choc
j'imagine
non j'adore c'est génial car il ya des
corbeaux aussi qui a taclé qui attaquent
les est oui alors en chine dit on
s'aperçoit que je colle période inventé
et moi personnellement je l' ai vu dans
mon jardin cette histoire j'ai à chaque
semaine milk shake est très gros et un
jour il sait il s'est tapé si j'ose
m'exprimer ainsi un petit poussin de pee
wee ellis se sont rassemblés au dessus
de lui et l'ont attaqué sont descendus
en cliquez sur lui n'est pire ont
attaqué le chat qui venait de le bouffer
à petit jeu méritait bien
mais ce qui est étonnant c'est que
pendant au moins un mois et n'a pas pu
sortir dans le jardin chaque fois qu'ils
auraient les pieds j'en étais arrivé à
ce qu aurait en fait c'est la même
histoire c'est un chien qui s'empare
d'un bébé corbeau voilà et évidemment
les cordons sont rendus fous par ça et
se met à attaquer bien sûr la
propriétaire du chien il est à côté de
son histoire extraordinaire ya bon vin
rouge est racontée mia les araignées
venimeuses c'est à dire la wii la fille
en afrique du sud qui fait tué sa soeur
par des araignées venimeuses elle mais
qu'elle met dans son lit ce qui est
assez sympathique
une autre histoire extraordinaire c'est
celle de vos parents qui se sont
rencontrés vos parents se sont
rencontrés dans un bal qui s'appelait le
magic city absolument et qui y était
associé aussi extraordinaire ce bal
était situé 15 rue cognacq-jay mais
quand on connaît votre carrière à
l'endroit où il ya eu après les studios
de télévision
oui ils se sont rencontrés là oui tout à
fait et d'ailleurs pourquoi est ce que
les allemands puisque ce sont les
allemands qui ont choisi chacun
reconnaisse pas les français du tout
pendant la guerre les allemands
installés sur cet emplacement donc leur
studio de télévision à destination des
soldats qui était en convalescence dans
la région parisienne
à quoi servait ce studio est donc il
s'était installé tout simplement sur les
restes de mammouths du magic city il y
avait donc une senne tournante qui a
utilisé ensuite la télévision d'ailleurs
pour ses premières émissions de variétés
par vos parents votre père est un aristo
il s'appelait dhostel d'ailleurs votre
fils qui fait du téléachat sa femme sa
maintenance appelé comme ça c'est vrai
c'était la baronne dhostel lui s'appelle
mark moi à oui s'était mariée avec un
roturier qui savait bellemare à m
guettez d'origine algérienne pinard est
alors votre maire si une petite
couturière de montmartre ah oui c'est
votre père donc fils d'aristo et votre
mère dont il y avait vraiment un
problème
enfin par un problème il ya une vraie
différence de classe oui ils se sont
aimés extraordinairement aux parents
c'est à dire que même quand votre père
avait des mets des problèmes aux deux
pères un moment été obligé de vendre ses
ruines et votre père tellement j'en
prends russe était obligé de vendre des
livres en porte à porte donc c'était un
c'est très difficile pour lui c'est déjà
du téléachat il est arrivé il sonnait
que c'était déjà assez de famille
maintenant qu'on est là il a d'abord
tendu de la colle ouais
dans les pays où avait lieu il bataille
de la guerre de 14 beaucoup de choses à
côté
ensuite il y avait dans les faits ici il
s'est mis aux livres et il y reste et
marchands de livres tout ça ils se
retrouvaient temps en temps à l'hôtel
avec votre mère pendant des années comme
ça vient il à la vraie il partait sur la
route on peut dire cinq jours sur sept
et en effet ils se donnaient rendez vous
se téléphoner parce que le téléphone on
l'utilisé très très peu à cette époque
et très peu de téléphones nous n'avions
pas le téléphone bon et avant de partir
faisait donc quand je reviens je
t'attends à tel endroit à telle heure et
se donner rendez-vous d'amoureux toutes
les semaines et donc évidemment y passer
une nuit d'amour folle à chaque fois
qu'ils se retrouvent et c'est donc tout
ils ont été à coup parfait et comme
toujours ce sont sur ces couples que
s'acharne les maladies les destins
divers et malheureusement ma mère est
morte d'une maladie terrible qui ronge
littéralement et qui s'appelle la
sclérose en plaques
et donc voilà
donc ce bel amour s'est terminée dans la
douleur total d'une maladie atroce alors
à 17 ans et demi vous rentrez à la radio
avec jean-jacques vital jacques antoine
enfin lé père fondateur de la radio et
la télévision française
et alors là vous inventer tous ensemble
ce qui sera là la radio et la télé
moderne alors des jeux comme 100 francs
par seconde c'était quoi s'en prend par
seconde
c'était des gens qui souffrent parce
qu'on signale temps qui tenait à weipa
sachant jacques vidal qui était
l'animateur de ce à lui il savait tout
et les autres devaient quand qui tenait
gagner alors il leur arrivait quantité
de choses hein c'était une mission
extrêmement visuel
d'ailleurs on est parti en spectacle
avec cette émission pendant des années
les gens se précipiter dans les salles
on était pop ou revoir ce spectacle
littéralement fortune avec cette
émission est en fait la radio faisait le
reportage en quelque sorte du spectacle
alors les des émissions aussi vous avez
fait des premières grandes émissions
mobilisiez des gens vous êtes
formidables et à faire mais il avait
surtout vous êtes formidable c'est la
naissance d'une chose qui alors est
inutilisé totalement à la radio n'a
jamais été utilisé ça paraît incroyable
mais c'est ainsi on n'avait jamais eu
l'idée avant vous êtes formidables de
téléphoner à un auditeur pour rentrer en
relation avec la wii donc c'est la
première fois qu'on utilise le téléphone
et comme on a pâti standard téléphonique
et un repas ya strictement aucun
standard eh bien on va être prendre le
standard qui existe à l'époque ce sera
svp et puis qui va devenir très très
célèbre grâce aux dossiers de l'écran
nationale au rebond où l'intervention a
pas toutes les citer et la tête et les
jambes et la caméra invisible il ya
cavalier seul ou laurent fabius a fait
ses débuts oui tout à fait les dossiers
extraordinaire et alors il ya la chose
la chose c'est l'objet visé un objet
mystérieux mais pas vous en faire
l'essai le schmilblick ont choisi c'est
une chose est faite nous jouer oui al
isawi est-ce que la chose est ronde
la chose que ce que j'ai choisi que vous
venez de choisir le nom esi est ce que
la chose est une femme non jeu se mange
non marion maintenant justement
est-ce que la chose est dur oui parce
qu'elle a la peau douce après l'amour
non est ce qu'elle se mange c'est à dire
qu'elle se sucent haute
aïe aïe aïe je vais plein de comprendre
est-ce que la chose et sucrés non
justement on suscite beaucoup ça mais
curieusement c'est plutôt mais ma mère
c'est un bâton de réglisse
c'est pas un bâton de réglisse mais ça à
peu la forme en effet d'un bateau du
bois de réglisse non non c'est pas du
bois de réglisse bc2 le mot bois peut
s'employer en ce qui concerne bois dont
on fait des pipes c'est pas du bois dont
on fait des pipes mais c'est un
consensus quand même écouter ça bouge
tout seul ah non mais on aime bien qu un
budget qui ne bougeait pardon ont pu
annoncer pas une fille maintenant non
pardon et ouais non non caisse conçue
sans fin qui est toujours mâchouiller
est lamentable un chewing gum
non si vous bougez l'islande est en bois
un crayon en main vous appelez comment
yannick barbe organisme venait de gagner
la chose qu'arnaud gagné quoi les gens à
l'époque
abbas était là toujours l'histoire de la
cagnotte était comme étaient tous les
jours tant dans la cagnotte est toujours
en trouver la cagnotte est mort mais y
avait 100 francs à cagnac je suis un peu
la rue alice de rpm jouissent et la
malice des retards et laurent 86 dont
vous êtes viré à l'âge de 55 ans vous
êtes viread la télé oui c'est la règle
et alors là vous effectivement pour que
vos revenus financiers ne dépende plus
seulement de votre carrière d'animateur
c'est là que vous intervenez vous
inventez donc le fameux téléachat oui
enfin l'adapt ouais on apprend on
l'avait lancé en france c'est ça on
adapte pour la france une idée
américaine qui n'est pas du tout fait
aux états unis comme elle est faite en
france car nous il va plus à s'intégrer
à un programme on va venir une émission
télé achat alors que aux états unis ce
sont les chaînes de téléachats craignent
que ça il veille au soir tandis que nous
nous allons créer un programme d'une
demi
à l'heure où on bat bodzen avec la
cloche à trois majors avec l'agglo
chaperonnage absolument